retraité et passionné par les armes en
tout genre depuis l'âge de 14 ans pier
richer et leurs inventeurs du flash-ball
experts et professeur de balistique
c'est en 1990 après cinq ans de
recherches dans un laboratoire installé
dans son garage qu'il a mis au point ce
fusil révolutionnaire je voulais depuis
longtemps faire le contraire de ce que
tout le monde avait fait petit calibre
et le but est qui qui font des trous et
je voulais venir au gros projectiles à
faible vitesse kit apport 100 blessés et
deux chiens
sam et pour tirer première détente que
je me détente un simple d'utilisation le
flash-ball et assure son inventeur sans
danger la balle est en caoutchouc mousse
tiré à une distance de 15 à 20 mètres ne
provoque au pire qu'un gros hématome la
taille de l'armée le bruit qu'elle fait
sont déjà dissuasif c'est pour cela que
plusieurs groupes d'élite comme le raid
l'ont adopté depuis plusieurs années un
avantage c'est pour eux qui ont une
terreur panique des bavures
c'est de neutraliser la personne qui
veulent appréhender sans qu'elles soient
obligées de passer l'hôpital ça c'est du
travail propre à j'ai du reste un
travail propre en plus on ne l'a pas tué
on peut le poser des questions ce sont
désormais les 300 policiers des brigades
anti criminalité qui vont être dotés de
flashball en plus de leurs armes de
fonction ceux de metz en possède déjà
depuis six mois
[Musique]